ORDER.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN BY
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DURING THE YEAR BIGELOW FRESNO
ACOSTA HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN. BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
DALY. GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON THEIR
GLORIA.
DON'T SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY FAIR.
LEVINE.
LOW.
RUBIO. SALAS. WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT SAY WE
HONOR. WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY EYES. BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.%
KILEY.
KILEY I LET LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LIVING AYE LOW. LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON.
BONTA AYE.
IF WE COULD LOOK.
GLORIA I.
IS JONES SAWYER WHO. WAS WELL.
KNOWN AND LOSE.
YEAH LOW VOTER.
THE ONE WITH JONES SAWYER.
IS THERE ANYTHING.
OKAY CONSENT CALENDAR ADOPTED
COMMITTEE ADJOURNED